Oh
you
hello and welcome i'm dave elliott
global product lead for storage products
here at Google I'm a former backup bad
man now spent most of my career in
storage and backup most recently I've
been helping shape Google's cloud
storage offering and I'm Randy serafini
senior product marketing manager at
veritas veritas is the market share
leader in back up with more than 34,000
enterprise customers we're here today to
talk to you about cloud storage backup
and some of the key aspects of making
the decisions on what and when to move
to the cloud as a backup target Dave
let's get started ok so today we'd like
to chat about some of the emerging
challenges that backup faces challenges
which make cloud more and more relevant
then we'll provide a brief overview of
what types of things you should be
thinking about when using cloud as a
backup target next Randy will provide an
overview of net back up and discuss how
it simplifies to move to cloud and then
I'll touch a little bit on our object
storage service named google cloud
storage will close with a few tangible
suggestions on where to go from here so
I'm sure you've been thinking about
using the cloud as a backup target for
some time the question are what's
changed and why now so there are
significant continued and emerging
challenges that we face we all know that
data is growing at a really really fast
rate for a variety of reasons generally
we're spiraling towards a future where
the digital world is overtaking our
entire storage infrastructure where
creation modification distribution of
digital assets is becoming easier and
easier but at the same time budgets for
storing and protecting that data are not
changing or at least not as quickly as
the data itself is growing the classic
do more with less drumbeat nit continues
another growing challenge for those nit
is that the responsible for data
protection and they need to align those
activities with business outcomes so
forward-looking CIOs have been
developing strategies for quite a while
on down how to make sure that they show
their investments are in fact aligned
with the investments of growth and not
just they're not just a cost Center
finally security compliance concerns
continue to be a major part of your job
whether it be a high-profile
security breach or new regulations the
cost of meeting these challenges is
really becoming significant that's right
Dave one emerging example is the
recently passed EU general data
protection regulation or GDP or GDP RS
gianna maybe that's gotta be a
government thing I say that five times
really fast this new regulation will go
into effect in Europe in 2018 it really
it requires a company to delete data if
it is no longer used for the purpose it
was collected and it requires a company
to delete that data if an individual
revokes the consent for that company to
hold the data regulations like these
have far-reaching implications to the
storage data protection backup in
archiving teams got it got it so its
data growth fixed budgets business
alignment and then the security of
compliance these are things that are
significant challenges now that's great
and back up yeah okay so let's think a
little bit about some of the challenges
than of existing backup targets when you
think about cloud you think about what's
the alternative so most of you probably
use or have used tape as your primary
backup target tape however has many many
limitations which are significant and
are becoming more and more problematic
in a world where data security
compliance and availability are critical
first let's talk about the speed of tape
no matter how modern the library you're
still working from the limitations of a
linear technology plus papers usually
stored off-site and of course offline
meaning it could take hours or even days
for you to get to tape back on premise
well nothing's new about this problem in
tape it's more significant of a
limitation in a world where on-demand
always-on is status quo second remember
that tape is a manual process with
physical devices tapes autoloaders
libraries that are managed by humans in
economic terms tape can be
labor-intensive but in ID terms is just
a pain that brings me to the third major
challenge of tape it can be an
unreliable process it's error-prone not
necessarily because tape is unreliable
but because there are multiple steps
multo devices and multiple people and
that leads to multiple potential points
of failure
Dave I think you made a mistake with
your slide where's the icon for error
prone well I had a great one but I
accidentally fat fingered it and deleted
it you know I am only human well now you
know why that's why people need backup
that's right they need to have a
secondary copy and it's a it not a
manual and error-prone one like tape
management so let's move on to the other
popular target disk disk is ideal for
delivery of hot data and has a lot of
uses in backup such as for deduplication
however a lot of folks over use disk
it's not designed for long-term
retention it's expensive and depending
on your architecture and design can be
really really difficult to scale so now
let's move on to some of the key
considerations of cloud storage as you
think about using it for cloud data so
we'd like to touch on three areas
technical considerations financial
considerations and operational
considerations let's start with
technical considerations this is the one
that most people think about first
storage has to be reliable you simply
can't ever lose data this might be
represented as durability redundancy or
geographic diversity second storage
should be available this is more and
more important can I get my data when
and where I need it this might be
reflected in latency global reach
network performance network performance
and stability and will likely have some
sort of service level agreement attached
to it third the data has to be safe in
the cloud as you mentioned earlier you
can't afford to fail in this front
important considerations is a type and
location of encryption access control
mechanisms and a track record a track
record of safety and security ask your
cloud vendor next let's look at
financial considerations prices continue
to fall on cloud so let's take a look at
how tape disk and cloud generally
compare so capital outlay our hardware
purchasing disk is expensive and cloud
requires no upfront purchases so cloud
has an advantage their capacity costs
are ongoing costs are typically very low
for tape but remember that's only a part
of storage for cloud in comparison to
tape you only pay for what you
actually use and you use it when you
actually need it while tape has shipping
and logistics for off-site storage
networking cost is higher for cloud as
you import and export data personnel
costs are higher for tape as it requires
as we mentioned some human intervention
some human activity and as high recovery
costs so to find out if it makes
economic sense for you I recommend
putting together a spreadsheet that
takes into account the real cost of tape
and the real cost of cloud will be doing
another in-depth webinar on the ROI of
tape versus cloud so keep an eye out for
that so now let's take a look at the
third major component here the
operational considerations of the cloud
so moving the little cloud you may have
organizational resistance from vested
interest it may be somebody's job it is
to manage the backups and they don't
want to change change is hard you may
have resistance from security teams or
from traditional IT that's not yet sold
on cloud so generally a best practice to
overcome that organizational resistance
is get by in early and make them a part
of the process engage your vendors
engage us to help you alleviate some of
these concerns second is workflow so
some of the organizational resistance
might come from people's jobs changing
so how do you best optimize generally
speaking I would say think about it
ahead of time prepare for having those
individuals be reassigned to value-added
services to create better alignment with
the business you also going to have
vested interest in existing vendors for
storage backup and generally speaking
the best practice there is simply be
prepared to switch though that isn't
typically something that is the major
inhibitor finally integration how
difficult is it to move to the cloud how
tightly integrated is a solution your
backup software should make it easy to
use disk tape or cloud great so now
let's talk about net backup and how that
backup makes it really really simple to
move to the cloud and really if you can
start with just explaining how net
backup views a world that helmet backup
is a differentiated product sure I'd be
happy to date thank you when we talk
about net back up we are talking about
highly scalable enterprise class data
protection for nearly as long as
I can remember and I've been doing this
for a while the typical enterprise is a
complex heterogeneous environment with a
wide range of applications running in
virtual systems physical systems and are
globally deployed in multiple data
centers with potentially thousands of
remote offices everywhere when you layer
massive data growth on top of these
complex global deployments coming from
potentially hundreds of thousands of VMs
as we see in some of our largest
enterprise customers on the planet you
need to be able to scale and manage
petabytes or exabytes or exabytes of
data no matter where it is located
without loss in performance what
enterprise customers tell us is they
don't want to run multiple point
products for their data protection the
reason for this is they end up with side
load solutions what not only adds cost
and are hard to scale but introduces
significant risk this additional cost to
train manage and orchestrate multiple
products but because the data protection
is now fragmented significant risk is
introduced through gaps in their data
protection that might be discovered only
when it's too late imagine the
challenges of trying to orchestrate
recovery from multiple products in the
event of a major disaster this is where
i'd like to introduce the netbackup
platform and the sheer power it brings
to the enterprise and what we call a
unified data protection solution unified
data protection yes is that is that
something that that people understand
unified data protection that actually is
a very common industry term you talk
about point solutions and then you talk
about unified data protection and that's
a great segue but I'm not going to tell
you exactly what unified data protection
is just yet so we think about point
solutions you think about somebody once
said that data centers are museums of
past IT decisions where you've got a
point solution to maybe to back up one
set of systems and another points
fiction set up another type typically
it's broken down either by typically
broken down by workloads so you might
have one application backing up physical
workloads another application data
protection solution backing up virtual
environments the list can be and you
could have different vendors coming in
because of acquisitions that you know
companies that are using different types
of solutions and it's not uncommon today
for a number of enterprises to have
multiple point solutions running in
their environment so so unified data
protection then is something that that
net backup is well known for oh
absolutely that is what we do in fact I
understand in the latest 2016 Magic
Quadrant report for data center backup
and recovery which I understand Veritas
has been in for what synonym for 17
years since the very beginning of the
Magic Quadrant and we are actually still
the number one market share leader in
backup and recovery huh so and in what
they had to say about netbackup is that
net backup is the most evaluated
enterprise backup solution and the most
deployed solution for organizations with
five thousand or more employees five
thousand or more employees a very very
large large organization that's exactly
right and the reason for this is simple
netbackup has perhaps the broadest
support for heterogeneous environments
across virtual physical and cloud and
cloud and allows the enterprise to
manage data protection as a holistic
solution all from a single console or by
workload and because netbackup is
designed as a ground-up unified data
protection platform which includes both
software and a family of tightly
integrated appliances netbackup has the
ability to manage data protection for
the globally deployed enterprise while
maintaining performance at petabyte or
exabyte scale correct and providing the
holistic global view of all enterprise
data without the added cost and risk of
point solutions the biggest challenges
enterprise customers tell us and we
talked to a lot of them is the need to
reduce complexity because with
complexity comes cost and risk they need
to be able to not only maintain
performance in the face of massive data
growth they need to manage and reduce
the cost of this data growth the next
hot topic is facing the CIO is how can
they become more agile be more efficient
and streamlined in their operations
eliminate bottlenecks and respond better
to new business challenges and
opportunities so simplicity and agility
these are important differentiators for
netbackup absolutely okay great so what
are some other it's another important
difference well the one thing that you
missed with scalability okay so you get
simplicity scalability and
okay great okay and finally is
visibility what they want is is they
want to be able to see all of their data
no matter where it is and be able to
better leverage that data or eliminate
data that no longer is of value met back
up 7 dot 7 brings to the enterprise what
we call a converged data protection
platform converge data protection
platform hold on Randy that sounds like
some good marketing fluff what does that
what does that really mean well but when
you think about it today we talked about
hypervisor converge platforms we talked
about infrastructure converged platforms
what that really means is a tight
integration between software and
hardware okay so what we have is a
unique combination of net backup
software and our integrated family of
netbackup appliances that not only
simplify the deployment of netbackup but
provide massive enterprise class
performance and scale across workloads
in the enterprise customers that have
moved and consolidated workloads to the
net backup converged platform have
discovered the ease and simplicity of
managing a unified data protection
platform across their deployment and
with the many performance features and
intelligent policies to automate and
accelerate backup and recovery they have
experienced significant improvements
both in both backup performance and
backup success rates as well as faster
recoveries not to mention what this
integrated into in the deduplication
significant reduction reduction in
storage footprint and costs and now I
know what a converge platform is great
correct yes it is fully integrated what
is important to keep in mind is that for
those companies that leverage a single
unified data protection solution that
protects all workloads and data they're
in a unique position with the right
information management tools to get
visibility into all their globally
deployed data back to visibility right
back to visibility the key to one of our
key differentiators whether that data is
on Prem whether its remote or in the
cloud in the cloud in the cloud
hopefully Google's cloud you can get
actionable intelligence a perfect
example of this right kind of tool is
our exciting new Veritas information map
solution that in a matter of minutes can
import net backups catalog and index
data and present a global view of that
data where it's located
how much is there and with the ability
to double-click and understand what kind
of data it is and more importantly does
that data represent unlocked value or
can that cost be eliminated okay now
that you have a pretty good idea of why
so many cuts enterprise customers love
net back up let's talk about cloud cloud
love it let's talk about cloud well I
thought you might like to do that okay
so we know today the world has an
expanding lineup of cloud vendors with
more coming online every day in just
about any flavor you can imagine this is
the good news and the bad news the good
news is that you have more choice and we
all love more choice the bad news is you
have more choice you can just pick
Google Cloud you could just do that and
make it simple right yeah well we're net
backup can play a key role with helping
to simplify your decision is its natural
ability to extend data protection and
management to the cloud as if it was
just another globally deployed
enterprise data center or target storage
device only now these resources are in
the cloud when you look at the real
bench strength of net back up it has the
ability to scale and protect these
workloads no matter where they reside
and can easily move in keep track of
this data whether it's on disk tape
appliance or in the cloud or even
multiple clouds so its scale and not
just scale in terms of more servers but
more servers across more locations and
more types no matter where it look where
it resides get great with net back up we
have a growing list of integrated cloud
connectors and data reduction
technologies and with a single click
from the net back up console you can
start target backups to your cloud
vendor of choice in addition to
connecting to your favorite cloud
provider of choice via net backup
integrated cloud connectors you can
leverage a wide range of cloud gate ways
such as NetApp's alta vault or store
reduce with deduplication that can
further reduce the cost of replacing
tape to the cloud our support for Google
near line is robust it enables to use
cloud storage as an alternative to tape
when choosing long-term storage of
backup data it also allows back up of
large volumes of data at a very low cost
and act can and get access to it at any
time this is great I don't need to talk
about in your line you're talking about
some of the great benefits no it's all
pretty simple once you use net backup
and target Google you're all set ready
together we can manage it for you
you've got your near line which I'll
talk about in just a minute let's talk
about integration through SD well OST is
one of our very special features it
allows storage vendors to actually
integrate tightly with net back up and
allows net back up to see all the data
where it's located within that storage
vendor and we do the same thing with
with all of our connectors with into the
club so by leveraging this unique OST
layer netbackup can continue to monitor
in back of all backup information
regardless of location whether it's on
disk on tape or cloud so you have net
backup lifecycle management capabilities
which also manage the wind and how
information is moved this is critical
whether you move from online disk or to
Google Cloud Storage Nearline great
recent enhancements in net backup 77
with multi screen technology
significantly improves when backup and
recovery performance by up to 30 times
for compatible cloud storage and a truly
unique enterprise feature a netbackup is
its auto image replication or net back
up air our customers love this feature
this technology allows companies to
automate and accelerate disaster
recovery through configurable when
optimize replication of deduplicated
backup images and catalog data to remote
locations many net backup customers are
looking to simplify their disaster
recovery by leveraging cloud platforms
as the remote disaster recovery site
with our air technology so
simplification we're hearing again
simplification we're hearing agility
scale and visibility and visibility ok
those are the real strengths of
netbackup great most importantly support
for google near line is single click
simple bring up the cloud storage you I
in that backup click on Google near line
and enter the Google credentials and you
are now ready to backup to the cloud
it's that simple fantastic now I'd like
to hand it back to Dave to discuss how
Google Cloud Storage is differentiated
and it's a great fit as a backup storage
target Dave it's all yours thanks so a
quick introduction of Google Cloud
Storage it's our cloud object store
which is a great place to store backups
google cloud storage allows you to store
access and manage your unstructured data
on Google's infrastructure so it's the
same storage that Google uses for images
in google photo
ohs gmail attachments Google Docs cloud
object store offers unlimited scale
global availability it's highly durable
and it has very very low cost so what
are some of the Google Cloud storage key
differentiators first our massive
scalability which means you'll never
have to be concerned with running out of
storage again second our global network
which we built a known means better
latency and more reliable network
performance third our price leadership
this means you know you'll be getting
the best value we compare favorably not
only to on prem storage disk and tape
but also to other cloud providers on
average we're thirteen to twenty percent
less expensive fourth what i'll call
interesting value-added services these
are cloud services you can apply to your
data when it's in our cloud things like
data analytics machine learning for
instance fifth all of Google's cloud
storage offerings use a consistent
single API no need to write API for
standard storage and another for archive
and then finally the tight integration
with backup solutions such as net back
up and back to connect means that it's
very simple to get started so now I want
to briefly introduce Google Cloud
storage services so we have three
specific services the first is standard
storage which is highly performant and
highly available and is ideally suited
for hot applications durable reduced
availability is exactly what its name
says it provides slight and lower
availability with the same durability
and performance and it costs a little
bit less near line though is ideally
designed for back your line is what
netbackup has tightly integrated into
its UI its low cost at only a penny a
gig per month but you do pay for reads
so it's ideally designed for those use
cases where you don't read the data
frequently such as backup it's highly
durable 11 90 bility built-in and again
it's integrated with net backup and
backup exec so now let's close with a
few ideas on where you can go from here
what and when do you move data to the
cloud data movie deal cloud any data
that's older than 30 days I think ninety
percent of backup restore 'he's are from
data that's less than 30 days so after
30 days you can move it to a cloud
that's correct but there's another
interesting statistic Dave and that is a
research has shown that after 90 days
ninety percent ninety-seven percent of
the data ninety-seven percent okay seven
percent is no longer accessed so think
about that you have all this data
sitting on expensive disk after 90 days
just sitting there so move it that's
what's a good place to do what's a good
thing to do over to the cloud is it
quickly as you can after 30 days or 60
days so data in remote office from
branches the typical Robo a use case
it's a great place for you the type of
data to move to the cloud because you
already have to traverse the network a
secondary copy of backup data sort of
disk to disk to cloud as you might call
it is a great set type of data that gets
moved data that's generally on Prem
that's filling Phyllis filled up your
data center filled up your your disk
array local fill up your local cache and
then data that's supporting a BCD our
plan so that's a type of data typically
you agree with that I do yes and then
the catalyst events you know the things
that drive people to make decisions to
consider cloud you know perhaps the
reason people are watching some webinar
right now first tape equipment is coming
off lease or is simply reaching
obsolescence you know so you need to
replace your tape second launching
perhaps a cloud first initiative
internally perhaps a server or desktop
virtualization project or wholesale
infrastructure upgrades it could be that
there's new people and people are
willing new people are willing to try do
things differently or it could be some
sort of consolidation initiative where
they're looking to take some of those
vast pools of tape and disk that are all
over their infrastructure and
consolidate them and create some
efficiencies so it's just a few ideas on
hopefully some tangible ideas on what
type of data typically gets moved to the
cloud and then some catalyst events so
very quickly a very high level
architecture a very simple architecture
that might look like either using direct
backup from net backup or any backup a
vendor directly to the cloud or
leb by leveraging a gateway I using that
back up through a gateway to GCS and
then finally I'd like to summarize and
do a simple recap now there are some
emerging challenges in backup backup
environment is changing with more and
more data more regulations and then a
desire or really requirement to better
support the business to better align
with the business tape and disk
limitations are even more significant in
this era right when high data growth
constrained budgets and not and
on-demand world and when thinking about
storage for backup there are technical
financial and operational considerations
that we barely touched on hopefully we
gave you a construct for you to think
about and for you to go and have a
conversation with your team as to
whether cloud make sense we finished
with introduction to net back up and how
net backups design for the entire for
the whole global enterprise and we
introduced Google Cloud storage near
line as a highly durable globally
available low-cost limitless data
storage pool that's tightly integrated
with net back up so finally a few
suggestions on where to go from here now
I try to make it as tangible as possible
first experiment it's the cloud right
it's designed to experiments he's on to
play with and reiterate Dave it's single
click simple because it's so tightly
integrated in it back up all you got to
do is pull up the UI pull up the storage
clout component of net back up and click
on google near line put the credentials
in and you now are ready to back up to
google cloud services so experiment try
it if you're a net back up user today
it's simple second thing is get buy-in
from stakeholders for some of those
stakeholders that were concerned with
changing their in their workday the
changing the process changing vendors
get buy-in from them early run the
numbers go ahead and create that
spreadsheet and go and get the real
numbers so you can compare the cost to
tape versus cloud versus disk don't
rhian decks your tapes and upload them
just cut over just leave the old ones
and let them age off let them expire and
then finally relate it to the
experimentation leverage the promotion
we
got a $300 new customer promotion
running right now we can go and sign up
in a few simple clicks it's literally I
think four minutes and you can leverage
that promotion with your net back up
instance today and get started and start
experimenting a couple of areas for you
to get more information you can read the
new ESG white paper on data protection
to the cloud and you can also of course
read the technical brief that is net
backup and Google Cloud storage so thank
you for your time and please look
forward to our other webinars Dave thank
you for inviting us to share net back up
with you and with you all of our
customers and potential customers out
there we're excited about the
opportunity to be able to use net back
up to leverage the cloud that's where
people are going that's where the
enterprise is going and we want to be
able to help enable that fantastic
thanks Randy thank you
Oh